اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي سحب الكتيبه
271 التابعه لوحده الهندسه القتاليه بعد
اسابيع من القتال في خانيونس وكان الجيش
الاسرائيلي سحب تدريجيا خلال الفتره
الماضيه بعد قواته حيث سحب الفرقه ال6
التي تضم لواء جولاني والويه من المدرعات
والمدفعيه والمشاه وقوات اخرى كما سحب
اللواء الخامس من قطاع غزه اواخر الشهر
الماضي الذي عمل في المنطقه الشماليه
لقطاع غزه على محور الشاطئ اضافه لسحب
اللواء الرابع احتياط والمعروف باسم
كرياتي من خان يونس بعد اسابيع من
العمليات العسكريه في شمال وشرق المحافظه
كما تم سحب اللواء 55 مظليين في صفوف
الاحتياط والذي عمل في منطقه خان يونس
وبعد شهور من العمليات في منطقه شمال
القطاع انهى الجيش الاسرائيلي الكتبه
7107 التي تتبع لواء
نحل